[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute nichts
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch rudi cerne für den sport hallo
schon gut meint und das sind unsere
themen heute
weiter chaos in kabul im gedränge vor
dem abgeriegelten flughafen sterben an
einem tag mindestens sieben menschen
afghanistan politik in der kritik
vizekanzler olaf scholz spd setzt im zdf
sommerinterview auf die diplomatie um
möglichst viele gefährdete menschen zu
retten
und dramatischer dreisatzsieg alexander
zverev zieht eben das finale von
cincinnati ein
[Applaus]
genau vor einer woche haben die taliban
die afghanische hauptstadt kabul viel
schneller als erwartet eingenommen und
dem westen vorgeführt seither versuchen
nato soldaten möglichst schnell
möglichst viele der verzweifelten
menschen rauszuholen am flughafen ist es
weiter extrem gefährlich immer wieder
werden menschen im gedränge erschossen
oder zu tode getrampelt tim kröger
schüsse am flughafen der afghanischen
hauptstadt kabul die lage bleibt
angespannt zuletzt sollen laut
britischen angaben sieben menschen bei
einer massenpanik ums leben gekommen
sein auch eine woche nach der
machtübernahme harren viele menschen am
flughafen aus die der herrschaft der
taliban entfliehen wollen unklar ist wer
wirklich die berechtigung dazu hat die
50-jährige hassiba erwartet mit
familienangehörigen seit zwei tagen und
möchte nach deutschland sagt sie
meine tochter und ihr kennt sinsheim wir
sind nur drei wir wollen nur raus mit
der heftung
hassiba hat es bislang nicht auf eines
der flugzeuge geschafft mit denen viele
länder staatsbürger und ortskräfte
ausfliegen die bundeswehr hat bislang
rund 2500 personen evakuiert erschwert
wird die groß angelegte rettungsaktion
am flughafen kabul laut der us regierung
durch die gefahr eines anschlags der
terrorgruppe islamischer staat die mit
den taliban findet ist und das
zeitfenster für evakuierungen wird immer
kleiner bis ende august will die us
armee ihren einsatz beenden dann gilt
eine fortführung der evakuierungen hat
kaum noch umsetzbar am kommenden
dienstag soll sich nachdem wir in der
britischen regierung ein virtueller g7
gipfel mit der lage in afghanistan
befassen
der deutsche städtetag verlangt von bund
und ländern rasch verlässliche angaben
wie viele flüchtlinge aus afghanistan zu
erwarten sind die hilfsbereitschaft sei
groß die aufnahme müsse aber organisiert
werden in mehreren städten haben sich
demonstranten dafür eingesetzt
gefährdete menschen aus dem krisenland
aufzunehmen die größte kundgebung gab es
im berliner regierungsviertel dort
forderten knapp 1000 teilnehmer
schutzbedürftige
unbürokratisch und schnell aus
afghanistan zu holen
die bundesregierung hatte die lage in
afghanistan völlig falsch eingeschätzt
entsprechend heftig hagelt es kritik
darum ging es heute auch im zdf
sommerinterview mit finanzminister olaf
scholz nach umfragen liegt der
spd-kanzlerkandidat derzeit in der
wählergunst deutlich vor armin laschet
und annalena baerbock andreas künast aus
potsdam
einen fehler wird olaf scholz heute
nicht einräumen anders als der
außenminister anders als die kanzlerin
äußerte der vizekanzler keine klare
selbstkritik die bundesregierung habe
die evakuierung der ortskräfte geregelt
so lange bis die afghanische regierung
zusammenbrach auf diese neuen umstände
werde nun reagiert es hatte priorität
ich habe die priorität gerade berichtet
wie man das hinbekommt und deshalb ist
es ja auch in der diskussion gewesen vom
verteidigungsministerium und
außenministerium zu gucken ob man die
frage der visaerteilung auch vor ort
hier in deutschland regeln kann das ist
jetzt auch so entschieden dass die
bundesregierung überhaupt über die
visavergabe diskutieren musste über den
abbau von bürokratie die enttäuschung ja
die wut darüber hat vor allem den
außenminister getroffen im
zdf-sommerinterview vermeidet scholz
heiko maas zu verteidigen der frage ob
er ihn als minister behalten will weicht
er aus
jetzt geht es um die arbeit die hier zu
leisten ist und wie die nächste
regierung gebildet wird das entscheidet
sich nach der wahl die verhandlungen der
bundesregierung mit den taliban
verteidigt scholz sie werden im
golfstaat katar in doha von afghanistan
botschafter markus poetzel geführt zum
beispiel schon zum schutz derjenigen die
später noch ausreisen wollen und dann
die möglichkeit haben müssen dass auch
um gesichert zu tun das ist eine frage
die gerade intensiv versucht wird zu
erreichen in den umfragen hat die spd
zuletzt deutlich aufgeholt bis in
reichweite der union olaf scholz
versucht jetzt keinen fehler mehr zu
machen oder keinen zuzugeben
dass ganze sommerinterview mit olaf
scholz auch zu den themen klimaschutz
und corona können sie gleich nach und
seen und jederzeit in der heute app
jetzt zu den corona zahlen die sind in
deutschland erneut gestiegen das robert
koch institut meldet 7050 neuinfektionen
innerhalb von 24 stunden das im
2322 mehr als vor einer woche außerdem
kamen binnen eines tages drei todesfälle
dazu die sieben tage incidents liegt
jetzt bei
54,5
bei einem vermutlich antisemitischen
angriff ist in köln ein junger mann
verletzt worden der 18 jährige sei
offenbar wegen seiner kicker aus einer
etwa zehnköpfigen gruppe heraus
attackiert worden heißt es nach ersten
ermittlungen zwei mutmaßliche täter
wurden vorübergehend festgenommen
der staatsschutz ermittelt
er ist russland dann die ukraine es sind
abschieds besucher von angela merkel zum
ende ihrer kanzlerschaft wie schon in
moskau warten auch in kiew schwierige
themen zum beispiel die russisch
deutsche ostsee pipeline nord stream 2
die ukraine verrichtet als gas transit
land wichtige gebühreneinnahmen zu
verlieren oder der dauerkonflikt in der
ost ukraine auch noch über sieben jahren
flammen die kämpfe mit russland nahmen
separatisten immer wieder auf für bürger
herzliche begrüßung ernste themen so
lässt sich der besuch der
bundeskanzlerin bei bole sln ski und
kiew zusammenfassen die ukraine ist
verärgert über das deutsch russische
projekt nord stream 2 das bald fertig
ist durch die ostsee pipeline wird
russisches gas nach europa fließen ob
und wie viel gas dann auch weiterhin
durch die ukraine geleitet wird liegt in
russlands händen und damit auch ob kiew
die bitter benötigten einnahmen in
milliardenhöhe aus dem gas transit
verlieren wird
es ist eine waffe eine gefährliche waffe
nicht nur für die ukraine sondern für
ganz europa
merkel verspricht sich dafür einzusetzen
dass auch weiter gas durch die ukraine
geleitet wird sollte russland energie
als geo politisches druckmittel
einsetzen droht die kanzlerin mit neuen
sanktionen
beruhigen kann das selensky kaum einig
sind sich die beiden bei einem anderen
thema das der auf eis liegende
friedensprozess für die ost ukraine
einen neustart brauche ich plädiere
dafür daran zu arbeiten noch einmal ein
treffen auf der präsidentin ebene und
bzw der politischen führungsebene mit
mir dem französischen präsidenten und
den russischen und den ukrainischen
präsidenten zu haben das wurde uns
fortschritte bringen
gipfeltreffen und friedensgespräche aber
zusätzlich bitte zielinski um deutsche
wasser worauf die kanzlerin mit
zurückhaltung reagiert hat
tropensturm grace hat nach haiti jetzt
auch mexiko erreicht mit extremen
windböen und andauerndem regen traf
grace im bundesstaat veracruz ausland
mindestens acht menschen starben durch
erdrutsche oder wurden in ihren häusern
verschüttet und die gefahr ist nicht
vorbei der sturm könnte über den pazifik
wieder an kraft gewinnen und erneut über
die küste hinweg ziehen
und jetzt zum tennis rudi da beglückt
alexander hleb seine fans absolut erhalt
von erfolg zu erfolg drei wochen nach
dem gold in tokio erreicht der hamburger
das finale beim atp masters turnier in
cincinnati usa in einem hart umkämpften
halbfinale gegen den griechen stefanos
zizi pass steht er am rand einer
niederlage und setzt sich am ende dann
doch noch in drei sätzen durch
so langsam könnte ihn selbst unheimlich
werden dann gegen den griechen stephanus
ziehe pass gelang alexander zverev
bereits der zehnte sieg nacheinander
dabei lag der hamburger im
entscheidungssatz nach zwei
aufschlagverlusten nahezu aussichtslos
schon mit eins zu vier händen und fand
trotzdem noch ins match zurück und das
obwohl er wegen schmerzen in der
magengegend eine medizinische auszeit
nehmen musste den tie-break angewandt
wäre gegen city pass ein schon verloren
geglaubtes match und trifft nun im
finale auf seinen russischen freund
andres
[Applaus]
in der fußball bundesliga trennten sich
hoffenheim und union berlin
unentschieden 2 2 die tsg verpasst damit
den sprung an die tabellenspitze
erneute glanzleistung durch jamaikas
sprint königin alan thompson hier an
beim diamond league meeting in eugene im
us bundesstaat oregon läuft die
dreimalige olympiasiegerin von tokio die
100 meter in 10,54 sekunden die
zweitschnellste zeit in der geschichte
thompson hier mit dreimal gold in tokio
die überragende leichter dating ist auch
drei wochen nach den spielen in
bestechender form nur fünf hundertstel
sekunden sind es noch bis zu einem bis
vor kurzem als unerreichbar geltenden
rekord 10,49 sekunden von florence
griffith joyner aus dem jahre 1988 sie
ist noch einmal um 7 hundertstelsekunden
schneller als bei den spielen von tokio
aus einer reihe von weltklasse
leistungen tragen auch die 23 meter 15
für den kugelstoß olympiasieger ryan
browser heraus nur 22 zentimeter unter
seinem eigenen weltrekord
so viel vom sport login dank rudi der
deutsche wetterdienst warnt vor
dauerregen im osten morgen scheint nur
ganz im norden die sonne sonst mehr
wolken und vor allem im südosten viel
regen örtlich auch gewitter die
höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 16 und
23 grad
so viel von uns danke dass sie sich die
zeit genommen haben bettina schausten
begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn im heute
journal
wir sagen tschüss bis morgen und
empfehlen jetzt das zdf sommerinterview
mit vizekanzler scholz